well suppose the way I'm giving these
[ __ ] compliment I hate me after this
Wow we going in damn I don't like read
it but it's so good for the soul I am
Vanessa van G Matteo and they are
forcing me to do I read you ah but
that's a mangie
my tale stand here before you had houses
in the et lounge I have to read them and
i slided me swears not my you know I
didn't come up with this it was them I'm
gonna roast and toast my season 11
sisters either by one word read or look
I'm supposed to read her how you read a
Curia country bumpkin tumbleweeds
because of the hair her hair looks like
a tumbleweed yes
season 11 11 inches of joking don't even
put that in their love for their
[Music]
personality or lack thereof
are we done in the words of Nina Buick
not even our old school Honda broke down
you own everything you own nothing
Nina Nina where's Nina go back south
so let me give you a face
[Music]
you're gorgeous
[Music]
delusional sugar cane Oh view I'm
currently in losing losing you know what
speak your mind and drink your cocktail
and tell RuPaul
then his out you got a fist [ __ ] you
know throughout the season she didn't
like she did not put a lot of deodorant
Thank You episode two got the boot [ __ ]
I've been wearing nothing but red
outfits look if I could go back in time
I want to swish some of those clothes
so [ __ ] do you not like any other color
but red the answer is no cuz I'm
standing here before you in red
no you crazy I'm stupid no but I love
you